Mohamed Ben Salman en Arabie Saoudite
Mohamed Sayed aux Émirats arabes unis et
Tamines althanie au Qatar tous trois on
vient de le voir avec ce documentaire
réalisé par Clémentine Mercier et Marco
trivilla veulent moderniser leur pays
imaginez un avenir sur le pétrole et le
gaz qui ont généré leur richesse et
faire demain de leurs états les places
fortes du jeu diplomatique au
Moyen-Orient ont-ils les moyens de leurs
ambitions et à quelles conditions et
bien nous allons en débattre maintenant
avec nos trois invités présents sur ce
plateau de débat doc aujourd'hui en
commençant par vous Christian Chesneau
bienvenue vous êtes grands reporter au
service international de Radio France
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient votre
dernier livre s'intitule le
Qatar en 100 questions les secrets d'une
influence planétaire il a été publié
chez Tallandier Emma Soubrié est
également avec nous bienvenue à vous
vous êtes on vous a vu d'ailleurs dans
ce dans ce film on vous a vu et entendu
témoigner à travers ce documentaire vous
êtes chercheuses associés à l'Institut
pour la paix et le développement qui se
situe à Nice et également à la word
puisse findation et puis enfin avec tout
billardi bienvenue à vous et vous êtes
professeur de droit public à
l'Université Paris Est Créteil chercheur
associé aux séries de Sciences Po Paris
vous chroniquez sur le site citizenweb
et vous êtes l'auteur entre autres de
comprendre le monde arabe c'est un
ouvrage qui lui disponible chez Armand
Colin on va commencer par une carte si
vous voulez bien pour resituer les
monarchies du golf dont on a parlé dans
ce documentaire en réalité ce film ne
parle que de trois des six monarchies
alimentaires qui apparaissent en rouge
vous le voyez sur cette carte avec bien
sûr principalement l'Arabie Saoudite
avec ses 31,5 millions d'habitants dont
les trois quarts ont d'ailleurs moins de
30 ans c'est une population très jeune
concernant les Saoudiens l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est la première économie du
Moyen-Orient aujourd'hui elle pèse 50%
du produit intérieur brut de l'ensemble
de ces monarchies du Golfe l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est aussi le premier
exportateur de pétrole au monde et le
deuxième producteur d'or noir au monde
les pays limitrophes vous les découvrez
également avec cette carte ils sont en
noir l'Iran tu es l'ennemi juré d'une
bonne partie de ces émirats du Golfe on
y reviendra sans doute dans un instant
l'Irak bien sûr on fête cette année en
2023 les 20 ans de la guerre d'Irak il
faut le rappeler la Jordanie l'Egypte le
Soudan et le Yémen ou l'Arabie Saoudite
continue de livrer une guerre
particulièrement
meurtrière on y reviendra peut-être
aussi dans un instant elle a cette
guerre et bien sûr été évoquée dans le
documentaire que l'on vient de voir ce
documentaire Christian Chesneau il a été
c'est vrai tourné maintenant voilà trois
ans les choses ont changé qu'est-ce
qu'il y a évolué durant ces trois années
qui nous séparent d'aujourd'hui de ces
quatre années maintenant la guerre et la
crise du golf plus exactement n'a pas eu
lieu le blocus évoqué dans ce
documentaire et organisé par à la fois
Barrail l'Arabie Saoudite et les Émirats
arabes unis face au Qatar c'est achevé
c'est en 2021 les pays se sont
réconciliés c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
comprendre oui au moins officiellement
en tout cas c'est vrai que beaucoup de
choses se sont passées en trois ans la
guerre des Princes a pris fin dans un
sommet à Oullins en Arabie Saoudite ou
finalement les pays qui avaient entamé
ce blocus contre le Qatar Bahreïn
l'Arabie et les Émirats ont finalement
enterré la hache de guerre et
aujourd'hui donc il y a une
normalisation entre entre ces trois pays
l'autre chose depuis le documentaire la
Coupe du Monde qui a eu lieu au Qatar
qui a été un grand succès malgré tout
malgré toutes les critiques et puis la
troisième chose chose qui est venu aussi
bouleverser la donne c'est pas la guerre
en Ukraine on assiste à quasiment un
troisième choc pétrolier ou gazé et ces
pays sont encore plus riches qu'avant
avant le documentaire et donc pour eux
ça c'est une une occasion d'avoir des
marges de manœuvre pour influencer pas
simplement sur sur les marchés
pétroliers mais sur surtout le reste je
le dire les Saoudiens les Émirats arabes
unis et Bahreïn accusaient le Qatar il
Égypte il faut rajouter l’égypte et
c'est très important accuser le Qatar de
financer le djihadisme c'était une
réalité est-ce que le Qatar a financé
pour partie
le djihadisme et l'islamisme radical il
y a eu des notamment en Europe par
exemple non il y a eu des accointances
sur le théâtre moyen le théâtre
moyen-oriento c'est-à-dire en Syrie il y
a eu effectivement des financements de
groupe extrémistes parfois liés alcaidea
en Libye etc il y a surtout une
connivence avec les freins musulmans
mais qui ne sont pas une organisation
terroriste en tout cas en Europe donc il
y a eu effectivement des zones grises
des zones d'ombres c'est ce que je parle
dans le livre mais le évidemment le
Qatar n'est pas la terroriste n'a pas
financé le terrorisme international
d'autres choses qui vous ont frappé dans
ce qui a évolué dans cette partie du
monde depuis le tournage de ce film en
2019 pour tout à fait pour rebondir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit je dirais que
une des nouvelles tendances et que non
seulement la crise du golf avec le Qatar
semble être enterré pour le moment mais
aujourd'hui on voit en fait poindre une
nouvelle compétition au sein du Golfe
qui se jouerait plutôt aujourd'hui entre
les Émirats arabes unis d'une part et
l'Arabie Saoudite d'autre part sur des
volets dont on reparlera sans doute de
préparation de la pré pétrole donc il y
a cette dimension là qui me semble très
intéressante et sur fond notamment de la
guerre en Ukraine ce qu'on a vu vraiment
évoluer ces dernières années c'est
l'autonomisation stratégique des pays du
Golfe et vraiment l'émergence d'un pôle
d'un pôle non aligné non aligné sur les
États-Unis mais également d'un alignés
sur la Russie et dans la compétition
aujourd'hui entre les États-Unis et la
Chine notamment aussi une volonté des
États du Golfe très nette de dire qui ne
sont ni avec l'un ni complètement à cela
ne vaut pas surtout pour l'Arabie
Saoudite dont on nous dit dans ce
documentaire qu'effectivement c'est un
allié historique des États-Unis mais
qu'aujourd'hui il se rapproche au moins
commercialement de la Chine et de la
Russie de la Chine et de la Russie oui
tout à fait donc c'est c'est valable
pour l'Arabie Saoudite mais aussi voir
surtout en réalité des Émirats arabes
unis aujourd'hui il y a une coopération
notamment sur le fond sur fond de
pandémique effectivement évidemment la
pandémie du coronavirus un élément quand
même nouveau par rapport à ce qui se
passait dans ce documentaire donc
contexte dans lequel les Émirats arabes
unis se sont énormément rapprochés de la
Chine il y a eu une coopération dont on
pourra peut-être sur laquelle on pourra
revenir
éventuellement quand on parlera de si on
évoque la préétrole mais il y a une
coopération en termes de de sécurité
sanitaire en réalité entre les Émirats
arabes unis et la Chine et vraiment de
préparation de ces de réponses à ces
autres aspects sécurité au delà le
politique et le militaire si vous voulez
mais il y a un autre événement qui n'a
pas été mentionné dans ce film mais
pourquoi ce qu'il est arrivé après 2019
c'est ce fameux accord d'Abraham ou les
Émirats arabes unis Barane le Soudan et
le Maroc également ont décidé de
normaliser leur relation diplomatique
avec Israël et ça c'est une première
oui effectivement alors c'est
intéressant par rapport aux trois états
qui nous intéressent aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où premièrement c'est une manière
de souligner que ce qu'il est réuni du
moins du côté saoudien du côté des
miracles Unis c'est l'identification
d'un adversaire stratégique commun
l'Iran et que cette identification là
cet adversaire commun le rappel permis
d'une certaine manière de normaliser à
des degrés différents leur relation
bilatérale avec Israël quand même temps
cette question de la normalisation avec
Israël ben même si un mouvement global
général s'est enclenché
incontestablement notamment grâce à une
présidence Trump qui qui a permis
d'autonomiser les acteurs régionaux en
golf et bien malgré tout malgré ou
au-delà de ce mouvement global on voit
bien que chacun sa propre partition une
gradation dans cette normalisation du
côté de mbz au nom des Émirats arabes un
c'est pleinement assumé au niveau
étatique et stratégique et ça se traduit
concrètement par le développement des
relations commerciales et autres du côté
saoudien ce n'est pas du tout encore
assumé à la fois sur le plan
diplomatique et sur le plan aussi
autrement dit ils n'ont pas décidé à ce
jour de normaliser leur relation
et mieux encore vous avez les
qatari carrément sont vraiment en
retraits par rapport à ce processus et
l'autre élément qui apparaît pas dans le
documentaire par rapport à finalement ce
petit décalage temporel je dirais que
c'est c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
puissance là assume
la volonté d'afficher d'incarner un
modèle alternatif finalement
au modèle occidental en ce sens où ils
assument une forme de modernisation et
de modernité même mais une modalité
modernité ça se serait qui ne se
conjuguerait pas avec la démocratie et
là pour le coup c'est très important
parce que ça ça fait résonance avec ce
que c'est d'incarner par ailleurs à
l'échelle internationale la Russie la
Chine avant la guerre en Ukraine entre
60 et 70% de la production du Golfe
était vendue au marché asiatique et la
majorité de la production d'or noir
russe était m'ont dit côté européen
aujourd'hui on observe que ça devient
l'inverse ça c'est pas du tout neutre
pour les pays dont nous parlons non
c'est pas neutre mais surtout ce qu'on
peut revenir un peu ce qu'on a dit tout
à l'heure il faut savoir que le premier
partenaire commercial de l'Arabie c'est
la Chine 90% du pétrole des émirats va
sur la Chine l'Asie l'Inde
la Corée du Sud et puis que le Qatar les
grands les grands clients c'est aussi
asiatiques pendant la coupe du monde la
Chine a quand même signé un contrat
historique avec le Qatar de livraison de
de gaz sur 27 ans donc là il y a une
bascule qui a été faite et aujourd'hui
évidemment les émirs se retrouvent un
peu encore au centre du jeu et vous avez
même aujourd'hui qui achète du pétrole
aux russe des des comtés à bas prix
parce que les Russes font des rabais
pour leur consommation intérieure et
revendent le leur aux autres donc voilà
ils sont ils sont au centre jeux du jeu
énergétique et puis ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que ça génère des leviers un
levier financier extraordinaire leur
font souvent dépassent les centaines de
milliards on parle peut-être de 3500
milliards sur la planète de fonds du
Golfe donc forcément ça leur donne une
puissance d'investissement d'influence
et on parlera tout à l'heure je lui
demande de transition énergétique
autrement dit pour bien comprendre
est-ce que les pays européens notamment
la France par exemple dépend de plus en
plus de ces pays en matière énergétique
notamment concernant la fourniture de
gaz aujourd'hui ah bah en tout cas sur
le Qatar la France via total qui a
remporté un très grand contrat de
d'extraction de de gaz justement avec
avec le Qatar a signé un contrat pour
qu'on importe d'ici deux trois ans du
GNF je crois que c'est un million et
demi de mètres cubes de génère pour la
France et les Allemands ont fait pareil
et tout le monde fait pareil tout le
monde va toquer à la porte de les
meilleurs pour notre dépendance
énergétique
s'intensifie de facto puisque avec ces
pays on se prive de la Russie
appartenant qui était le un des plus
grands le plus grand le numéro 1 au
monde sur le gaz etc il faut bien
trouver d'autres sources alternatives
est-ce que cette guerre en Ukraine et la
hausse du prix du pétrole évidemment
qu'elle a généré est une bonne affaire
pour les pays dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui de fait incontestable dans
quelle proportion
je dirais que on fait on est sur quand
même une tendance qui était déjà visible
dont je parlais tout à l'heure
d'autonomisation stratégique de ces
états une volonté de l'ensemble des
dirigeants de ces états de dire nous ne
sommes pas des soufres des pays
occidentaux nous avons une véritable
vision pour la région voir au-delà je
crois qu'on le voit dans le documentaire
on voit le le prince héritier me ramène
bensalman parler de d'une volonté de
voir le Moyen-Orient dominer le monde
désormais c'est quand même c'est ce sont
des mots très son objectif c'est ce
qu'il a déclaré à l'occasion d'un
colloque qui a été tourné à l'occasion
de ce documentaire en articulant et
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant à la
fois des vecteurs de Harper la puissance
énergétique c'est un élément un levier
important pour la puissance de ces de
ces monarchies du Golfe mais qui se
conjuguent de plus en plus avec un
savoir-faire en matière de soft power il
y a une volonté de conjuguer les deux
aspects cette capacité à influencer
notamment en jouant de de l'image et de
vecteurs comme le sport les
l'organisation d'événements qui
précisément font encore une fois écho et
une forme de modernité c'est là où le
modèle est assez complexe est assez
intéressant à étudier c'est qui sort un
peu des canons et de la caricature qu'on
pouvait avoir par rapport à ces
puissances là
l'autre chose très importante c'est que
pour la première fois j'ai dit les Emir
du golf on dit non aux Américains
c'est-à-dire que c'est quand même une
région qui était sous domination
américaine on parlait tout à l'heure de
la guerre du Golfe il y a 20 ans
aujourd'hui quand les Américains Joe
Biden demandent à l'Arabie aux Émirats
d'augmenter leur production pétrolière
ils disent NON et ça c'est une première
parce que ça sera pas passé il y a 20
ans donc il y a une forme évidemment de
d'autonomisation comme on a dit
stratégique et puis surtout on a
l'impression que l'Occident je dirais
pas en possession de faiblesse mais doit
composer maintenant c'est à dire que
c'est un marchandage et sur le cas de
l'Arabie Saoudite on se souvient 2018
l'assassinat de journal cacheguy à
Istanbul qui avait quand même un
événement énorme Joe Biden parlait de
mes MBS d'un paria
idem du tout récemment il y a quelques
mois à rencontrer MBS Emmanuel Macron
l'année dernière a aussi fait le voyage
à Jeddah donc voilà ça veut dire aussi
que ces pays deviennent incontournables
ça dit aussi surtout en fait on voit
bien que à travers la focale la
concentration notre attention sur ces
pays sans ça ça en dit beaucoup plus sur
l'état du monde et ce qui est en train
de se reconfigurer la scène
internationale est en train de se
reconfigurer c'est l'un des enjeux de la
guerre en Ukraine aussi on parle d'un
nouvel ordre mondial mais qui se
caractériserait par quoi premièrement
par le fait que il n'existe il existe de
moins en moins d'alliance stable fixe
au-delà du bloc occidental c'est
puissance du Sud qu'on a qualifie de Sud
globale finalement ce sont pragmatique
elle salit à d'autres puissances en
fonction du dossier du sujet du contexte
international il n'y a plus de de droit
acquis si j'ose dire y compris vis-à-vis
des États-Unis et puis l'autre élément
c'est que du côté occidental aussi plus
que jamais le discours enfin ce soft
power cette cette attractivité d'un
modèle qui se voulait universel plus que
jamais est affaibli parce que il y a une
incapacité à l'incarner et à être
crédible par rapport à ce type de
discours et le cas de de de du du
discours diplomatique
post-assassinat de du journaliste kasogi
et tout avait révélateur du fait que
tout le monde s'aligne sur un discours
de real politique extrêmement cynique
alors le grand enjeu on l'a bien compris
aussi à travers ce film c'est bien sûr
la prepro pétrole est-ce qu'on est déjà
dans cette phase là dans ces pays est-ce
que cette phase est déjà entamée et
comment comment les pays dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui peuvent espérer ne
plus être dépendants de l'hydrocarbure à
terme je dirais que c'est tout à fait
possible si on regarde un élément qui
est en fait très important dans le
contexte international actuel dont on
dont on vient de parler qui est qu'en
fait la puissance des pays du Golf
aujourd'hui elle repose certes sur le
fait qu'ils sont producteurs de pétrole
sur cette manne pétrolière mais dans Man
pétrolière les deux mots sont aussi
importants l'un que l'autre pétrolière
mais aussi man on parlait tout à l'heure
des fonds souverains des pays du Golfe
en fait les fonds souverains leur
permettent d'investir tout autour de la
planète et ces investissements et les
retours sur investissement que ça génère
vont permettre et c'est déjà le cas donc
à ce titre c'est déjà entamé vont leur
permettre d'entretenir cette manne
qu'elle soit en fait pétrolière ou un
retour sur investissement si vous voulez
donc on garde une puissance financière
dans un monde où les flux financiers
sont en fait de plus en plus important
qui leur garantit à la fois une
centralité dans les relations
internationales mais aussi leur permet
effectivement de mettre en place ces
plans de modernisation à l'intérieur de
leurs états ça c'est une formidable
force de frappe vous allez citer un
chiffre tout à l'heure on peut les
évaluer c'est fond souverain issus de
ces émirates aujourd'hui j'ai vu ça dans
la presse c'est-à-dire que les fonds
souverains au niveau international c'est
à peu près 7000 milliards il y en aurait
la moitié c'est-à-dire 3500 milliards
dans le golf le Qatar c'est 450
milliards 500 milliards les Émirats je
crois c'est 700 ou 800 milliards les
Saoudiens veulent faire le plus grand
fond au monde je crois ils veulent
arriver à 2000 milliards donc avec cette
manne financière et là vous l'avez dit
on investit effectivement à l'étranger
on se fait une cagnotte alors on a vu ce
qui est où et pour espérer en tirer quel
revenu des revenus pour les générations
futures on investit dans les grandes
entreprises dans l'immobilier un peu
partout et puis on a sur la transition
énergétique sur place c'est-à-dire que
ils sont déjà dans le soleil on a parlé
de la Coupe du monde où les stades
étaient électrifiés par du soleil ils
sont déjà dans l'hydrogène c'est à dire
qu'il y a des grands projets d'hydrogène
en Arabie Saoudite l'Arabie Saoudite
veut devenir le premier producteur
mondial d'hydrogène d'ici une dizaine
d'années dans le sultanat d'Oman donc on
est dans cette transition et eux leur
force c'est qu'ils ont les moyens de
leur ambition et c'est ça et c'est ça
leur grande force et qui peuvent payer
ils ont à la fois l'espace
désertique des populations pas très
nombreuses on l'a dit et puis un capital
énorme qui leur permet d'investir sur
place et puis de prendre des
participations tout récemment le Qatar a
pris des participations dans RWE le
grand électricien allemand ces
investissements notamment dans le faire
parce que ça c'est effectivement très
très sensible notamment du côté de
l'Arabie Saoudite mais pas seulement on
peut penser que ça va avoir la même
ampleur financière et dégager les mêmes
bénéfices que que le dégage le pétrole
pas forcément mais en tout cas Norman
est tellement grande et il y a le 13h
est tellement grand et qu'on peut faire
fructifier on peut garder comme ça 25 30
40 ans d'avance et puis après bah le
monde s'électrifier et ils ont peut-être
d'autres choses on parle notamment de
l'hydrogène quand on vit on vit les
projets exister tout à l'heure ces
visions 2030 2035 de de ces pays on voit
aussi qu'on veut faire de ces pays des
des destinations touristiques des
îles qui devient qui deviendrait zone
franche par exemple pour pour certains
pays est-ce que ces pays peuvent tirer
vraiment profit de ce genre de projet
est-ce que ça serait rentable il y a
certainement un problème d'adéquation
entre le discours l'ambition affichée
par les uns et les autres et la réalité
mais ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
vraiment cette volonté d'afficher une
capacité stratégique une capacité une
capacité cette projection on en est plus
à l'image des monarchies du Golfe qui
gérait juste une manne pétrolière qui
était plutôt dans des débats dans des
investissements stratégiques on était
plutôt dans finalement la profiter et la
rente effectivement
là on est dans la production pardon là
on est passé dans la production on est
dans la projection on est dans dans des
choix stratégiques dans des réflexions
on a maintenant aussi des élites qui ont
été formés dans les meilleures
universités occidentales qui reviennent
au pays pour mettre en
mettre au service leur capacité de leurs
compétences et tout cela est nouveau et
ça permet de donner de la consistance au
discours sur la modernisation du pays et
moi je trouve que c'est l'un des enjeux
de ce qui se passe c'est vraiment savoir
si ça va fonctionner et si ça fonctionne
c'est problématique aussi pour le modèle
qui était le plus attractif jusqu'ici le
modèle occidental qui alliés croissance
économique réussite économique et modèle
politique fondé sur le principe
démocratique là on a des autocraties en
fait des dictatures faut bien et
d'ailleurs politique de modernisation
autocratique
vous pouvez nous expliquer exactement
parce que évidemment on a une très belle
image comme ça qui nous est rendu
souvent d'ailleurs par des campagnes de
communication très importantes en venant
notamment des des Saoudiens
effectivement modernisés
liberté et puis à l'intérieur des pays
qui qui contrôlent la société civile et
qui dirige leur pays d'une main de fer
là aussi il y a quand même quelques
paradoxes qu'il faut peut-être souligner
non il y a tout à fait des paradoxes
après ce que je pense qui est un
particulièrement intéressant dans le cas
du Qatar et des émirats c'est que vous
avez vous avez vous êtes face à des pays
où la population locale est en fait
absolument minoritaire au sein de du
pays vous avez moins de 15% de la
population locale
moins de 15% de la population du Qatar
qui sont qatari tout le reste c'est des
expatriés de divers horizons mais donc
ce que ça signifie c'est que la main de
fer elle est surtout sur pas de pas de
représentation politique pour la
population locale on a beaucoup parlé
sur fond de coupe du monde notamment au
Qatar certes la main de fer elle est
aussi sur une partie de la population
importée en termes de main d'oeuvre etc
jugé une humaine et des conditions
écologiques pour le moins discuter qu'on
retrouve en l'occurrence au Qatar aux
Émirats en Arabie bon c'est le modèle le
modèle dans l'ensemble de ces états
actuellement ce qui est intéressant
c'est vraiment une
il y a une tension entre cette
modernisation
autoritaire vis-à-vis de la population
locale mais vraiment un soft power
d'ouverture sur le monde et d'essayer
d'attirer notamment des élites du la
jeunesse dorée notamment du monde entier
dans des poches d'ultra liberté au sein
même de ces états Christian chez nous
vous avez l'habitude de dire c'est le
Nouveau Monde finalement ces émirats
ce nouveau monde c'est les Bédouins du
troisième millénaire c'est à dire que
c'est des gens qui ont compris la
mondialisation presque avant tout le
monde ils ont compris qu'ils étaient
géographiquement au centre entre l'Asie
l'Afrique et l'Europe et moi j'ajouterai
pour compléter ce qu'on a dit c'est
qu'il y a deux éléments pour le la
Russie de ces modèles ou pas c'est
d'abord la sécurité donc c'est des pays
où la sécurité est tenue d'une manfait
une trace sécurité ultra sécurisée c'est
à dire que vous soyez au Qatar à Dubaï
vous pouvez laisser les clés sur la
voiture personne vous la prendra donc ça
c'est une condition c'est du succès
quand vous regardez là la région autour
l'Irak l'Iran le Soudan le Yémen
j'allais dire c'est une région au
chaotique vous avez là une zone tenue
sécuritairement et puis l'autre chose on
le voit un peu dans les commentaires
c'est le temps c'est à dire que ce sont
des jeunes les trois leaders 35 50 ans
etc donc on a le temps c'est à dire que
contrairement à nos démocraties pour
rebondir un peu sur l'aspect politique
nous tous les 5 ans ça change aux
États-Unis tous les quatre ans eux
Mohamed belsmann s'il arrive au pouvoir
il en a pour 40 ans donc forcément il
peut changer
son pays de A à Z donc ça ça évidemment
c'est des conditions qu'on a pas
forcément effectivement en Europe
d'ailleurs c'est l'un des éléments
fondamentaux de de ce modèle qui
exportent pas forcément expressément
mais qui s'exporte de fait la stabilité
déjà c'était
principal motivation pendant les
soulèvements de 2011 dans le monde arabe
leur crainte c'était finalement que
cette vague Athènes monarchie atteindre
le Bahreïn qu'on a pas besoin
et s'il y avait pas eu l'intervention de
l'Arabie Saoudite
un changement au sein de de ce royaume
mais ce qui est intéressant vraiment
c'est le culte de la stabilité sur fond
d'autorité et tout cela encore une fois
fait écho par rapport au discours assumé
cette fois-ci du côté chinois et russe
où il y a cette volonté d'exporter un
modèle de gouvernance alternatif à la
démocratie de marché là c'est un autre
modèle et d'une certaine manière il y a
peut-être là une source de de
rapprochement entre ces monarchies du
Golfe et ses puissances et grandes
puissances mondiales qui essayent de
remettre en cause l'ordre international
libéral et le leadership américain que
dire aujourd'hui du prosélytisme
concernant le wahibisme qu'on appelle le
salafisme en dehors des frontières
saoudiennes et du financement des Frères
musulmans qui ont longtemps été financés
vous l'avez écrit dans vos livres par le
Qatar le prisme a changé c'est à dire
qu'effectivement quand on va en Arabie
Saoudite aujourd'hui
un tel changement pour les femmes MBS à
dire à mis fin à la police religieuse
donc le prisme religieux n'est plus
forcément très opérant là on est dans le
business dans on construit des
entreprises l'enjeu aussi c'est des
jeunes on Arabie vous avez beaucoup de
gens vous l'avez dit et 30 % de chômeurs
donc il faut donner du travail aux
jeunes donc il faut se concentrer sur
l'intérieur et donc on passe du
religieux a eu tendance à reculer moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est une clé de
lecture aussi pertinente qu'avant j'ai
pas que il y a pas encore des reliquats
et que ça reste pas un sujet mais je
pense le vrai sujet effectivement c'est
le business aujourd'hui absolument une
volonté de Mohamed bensonman d'asseoir
ça ça montait en puissance au sein du
royaume sur une mise à distance
justement du religieux
le sport ça sert à ça la Coupe du monde
sans que ça s'accompagne pour autant
d'une véritable libéralisation du régime
c'est-à-dire que le le retrait la mise
en retrait du du religieux ne sait pas
accompagner d'une libéralisation
politique donc d'une certaine manière
c'est une si j'ose dire une forme de
laïcisation du pouvoir faire sa
légitimité ça le religieuse n'est plus
mise en avant de manière systématique et
absolue c'est plutôt le côté voilà
monarchie héréditaire qui fonctionne
c'est-à-dire qui est efficace grâce à un
type de gouvernance qui a étant qui
tendrait à faire ses preuves ce qui est
largement discutable naturellement par
ailleurs parce que l'Arabie elle est
dans le mur c'est-à-dire que ce système
avant s'il avait été en Arabie avant
2015 les femmes étaient séparées dans
l'espace public dans les restaurants
dans les banques voilà enfin c'était il
y avait pas de musique pas de concert
enfin c'était un pays quand même assez
moyen un jeu entre guillemets et c'est
vrai que là ça fait a fait un peu tout
exploser et donc il parie sur la
jeunesse quoi et la jeunesse qu'est-ce
qu'elle a envie et ben elle a envie de
Twitter elle veut des elle veut s'amuser
douce sauf power dans le dans le sport
le loisir et on a la Coupe du monde et
c'est le début ils espèrent avoir
peut-être les Jeux Olympiques l'Arabie
veut peut-être avoir la coupe du monde
de foot avec les Égyptiens et les Grecs
en 2026 là il y a un appétit pour à la
fois créer de nouveaux secteurs
industriels parce que ça fait de
l'emploi du business et puis dans
l'image je veux dire finalement le sport
c'est la nouvelle religion donc on
oublie le wahabisme et les freins
musulmans on en revient on en revient
encore une fois ce modèle alternatif le
capitalisme aussi débridé peut très bien
fonctionner sans démocratie c'est
vraiment le postulat de ces régimes et
là ça fait à nouveau écho au modèle
chinois par ailleurs qui n'a rien à voir
a priori mais le postulat fait qu'il se
rejoignent et c'est l'un des enjeux du
siècle savoir je voudrais rebondir là
dessus je pense qu'effectivement en fait
les pays du Golf ils sont ils incarnent
le capitalisme dans dans tout ce qu'il a
de plus débridé mais du coup ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il a pu aussi
faire la bascule avec les lits business
comme on le voit dans le documentaire
c'est à dire que la famille Trump etc
elle est très proche des pays du Golf
parce que tous ces gens là démocratie ou
pas démocratie parle avant tout
capitalisme il y a un banquier qui me
disait récemment je passe plus de temps
dans le golf qu'avall Street et ben
cette fois ça sera le bel et bien le mot
de la fin merci vraiment à vous trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat doc où nous
avons parlé aujourd'hui bien sûr des
émirats du golf vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag des badoxes sur Twitter nos
invités pourront d'ailleurs réagir à ce
que ce qu'on vaut vos réactions merci à
c'est le massalik comme à l'habitude m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission puis moi
je vous donne rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]